since the 2008 financial crisis hit
Europe Greece has been bailed out twice
by the EU its central bank and the IMF
in exchange they imposed austerity
measures that have shrunk the economy by
over a quarter spiked unemployment to
twenty-five percent and caused major
social unrest Germany led by Chancellor
Angela Merkel has been playing chicken
with Greece over a possible debt default
and a so-called grexit from the eurozone
enter Alexis tsipras the leader of
syriza a fringe political party that
means the coalition of the radical left
snap elections are set for January 25th
and for the first time syriza is leading
in the polls tsipras plans to end the
era of austerity and bargain Greece's
debt down to half other austerity
stricken countries in Europe like Spain
and Ireland are watching to see if it's
going to be a Greek tragedy or comedy
you